good morning everybody hi I'm Ellie
powers and I'm a product manager here on
the Google Play team we have so many
different announcements about what's new
for all of you app developers on Google
Play that we had to create one session
with a whole bunch of people to take you
through all of them but before we get
into that I want to take a couple
minutes to talk to you more about why
I'm really excited to work on Google
Play I've been on the team for about
four and a half years and one of the
things that really gets me excited even
now is really meeting each of you and
hearing your stories for every app and
game on the Google Play Store
there's a real story behind it you know
I love hearing how did you come up with
that idea for that newer app or game
what's really special about it to you
and I love trying out all the different
apps and seeing how they work and I love
hearing about what happens after you
launch your app how it's helping you
build a business and how you're using
that app to really transform people's
lives so before we say what's new in
Google Play we're gonna see a video and
take a look at some of your stories
let's play the video I started running
at marathons to raise money for
Parkinson's research in honor of my
grandfather I always had this idea that
if I could get enough people together
then collectively we would have the
clout of a celebrity and then companies
would want to sponsor us being on the
Android platform has enabled us to reach
people all over the world they can help
raise money for our charity partners and
it's helping
it's really cool to take your hobby and
put it into your full time job torque is
an android app that allows you to see
all the sensors on your vehicle and to
look at fault codes from the way it's
happened on the Google Play Store I've
touched over a million people with yeah
the communities dragged me along with it
and told me what they want I've done
that for the I'm very grateful and it's
staggering to see that something I've
written from my garden shed is liked by
that many people
we started right after University it was
myself my husband and his brother making
games was our childhood dream and this
is what we wanted to do since release
cooking favorite on Android it totally
clicked we realized that this is the way
to go and this is the platform of the
future we had millions of downloads in
the first weeks when we started it was
just three of us and now we're a company
of over 100 people making games that we
decide we want to make this has been
very successful
I really love watching this video
because it really shares the diversity
of different developers that we have
here in the Android and Google Play
community so now let's get on with
what's new on Google Play this year here
at Google we found that we build the
best products when we're able to launch
and iterate our products using user
feedback products like Gmail Chrome maps
and Google search are all great examples
of how we've been able to do this and we
want app developers like you to be able
to do the same things so Google Play has
been giving all of you the biggest user
base right access to a very wide range
of people all around the world but now
it's also become the best place to
optimize your apps to take on user
feedback and to make that measure how
your app is doing and to make those
little tweaks to make your app truly
great so I mentioned that I bought it
brought a big big team of people to help
me deliver these announcements so
lightning talk style
we're gonna bring each of them on to
share something new on Google Play with
you and with that I'd like to bring out
our engineering director miles Barr
hi I'm Miles bar I'm here today to talk
to you about the pre-launch report
it's exciting new feature that we
launched at Google i/o this year the
pre-launch report is built on the
firebase test lab the firebase test lab
is our data center of real Android
devices where you can test your app it
allows you to test your app across a
variety of devices Android OS versions
and languages it's already performed
over 1 million tests for developers like
you you can run your own custom tests
straight from Android studio or from the
firebase console beta testing has always
been one of the most popular and
powerful features but we wanted to make
it even better by performing a
comprehensive set of tests on your app
before it goes live you can now opt in
to generating a pre-launch report for
every apk you upload to the alpha and
beta channels in Google Play releasing a
new version your app can be a exciting
time but you want to make sure
everything goes right after about an
hour you'll get a report summarizing any
issues we found when testing your app
the first thing we look at is the
stability of your app we use the
firebase test lab to run your app on
real devices telling you on which
devices your app crashed on startup or
if it crashes offer a deeper crawl of
the app this means it won't be your
users finding the crashes and giving you
one star reviews we also show you what
your app looks like on these different
devices you get to see how it looks like
in different screen resolutions Android
OS versions and languages this allows
you to spot any problems such as
overflowing text in your translations
before your app goes live allowing you
to fix it quick fix them quickly and
easily the final part of the report
highlights any security vulnerabilities
we find this includes any versions of
third-party libraries with known
vulnerabilities or if you've
accidentally followed any security
anti-patterns
previously this information was only
available after your app
gonna live the pre-launch report brings
all this information together telling
you about these potential issues
allowing you to fix them before your app
goes production ensuring that you and
Google Play give your users the best
experience possible now I'd like to
bring on stage Kobi Glick product
manager for Google Play thank you thanks
miles
hi I want to talk to you about beta
testing beta testing is the most popular
feature on the Google Play Developer
console 60% of the top 1,000 apps on
Google Play are running a beta test
right now and users notice it apps the
trynna beta tests have higher rating on
average last year we made it easier for
users to discover and join beta programs
with open beta it's as simple as
clicking a URL we know that you love and
use beta testing and we often get
developer feedback like the one you see
from pocket telling us how birra testing
helps them connect to their users get
feedback on your ideas and make sure the
app is ready to go to production to make
it even easier for users to discover and
join beta programs we will allow users
to join them directly from your store
listing page on Google Play this will
help you grow larger beta programs and
connect to more testers now once you
have beta testers you want to get their
feedback right you used to get the
feedback through various sources and had
to parse a lot of information we will
allow users to give you private feedback
directly for Google Play this feedback
is private it goes only to you and you
can see it in the Google Play Developer
console private means other users don't
get to see it and it doesn't impact your
app star rating now we believe that apps
should run an open beta test even before
they go to production this is why we're
introducing a new section called
early access on Google Play this section
will feature exciting apps and games
that are still in development
are running a beta test and haven't
launched to production yet this will
allow early adopters and influencers
discovered those apps try them out and
give you valuable feedback helping you
find product market fit earlier and find
you in your games KPIs in our first
collection we have 28 apps and games as
you can see here with some pretty cool
tiles for example red feed an Android
first online book club or Ava the
founder whose parents and sisters are
deaf created this app to help deaf
people and people with hearing
disabilities to participate in real life
conversations we have Lego the kids and
family power brand with their first ever
in-house mobile game it's a 3d Lego set
you can touch twist and build just like
the brick sets we all grew up with this
is not just for free-to-play titles
never alone a gorgeous game developed by
Eline media who research together with
the alaskan natives is coming to Google
Play on early access as a premium title
we are sure that those changes that
we're making to be the testing will help
you grow even bigger beta programs get
feedback from users and make your apps
and games even more awesome thank you
I'd like to invite way chai an
engineering manager and Google Play
thank you hi I'm here to talk about some
new feature for play apps discovery
Google Play is the primary destination
for discovering apps and games on
Android today we provide various ways in
the store to assist users in finding new
apps and to drive developer outcomes by
helping you get discovered recently
we've been developing and experimenting
with a new way for users find new apps
contextual app discovery it targets
underlying needs that drive when and why
you might need new apps these needs
could be the ones in our everyday life
such as learn something new plan a
vacation or eat at home our user studies
show that most users look for new apps
at a time the Anita therefore we want to
explicitly target the knees by building
contextual collections of apps so that
users can find complementary apps needed
at the same time it also makes it easier
for users to find apps or types of apps
they may not have heard of before come
into play for example imagine a user is
searching for wallpaper we might
recognize user is interested in a
broader need personalize my phone and
show complementary apps including not
only wallpapers but also personalizable
keyboards themes and ringtones
similarly o let's take a look how it
works we identify the underlying needs
based on users searches
use count as an interest and show
complimentary apps around the need on
such result pages app install pages or
home pages when it makes sense to do so
so another example if the user is an app
install page for julia maybe he or she
is buying a house and will show great
other apps for finding houses for sale
calculating your mortgage and doing
interior design if a user is traveling
to San Francisco we might anticipate the
user's needs for apps for upcoming trip
and show a collection of relevant apps
for exploring San Francisco and the
users home page to further demonstrate
idea if you look at your place to our
home page now for some of you based on
your interest and context we're showing
a collection of apps called best of
Google i/o where you can find nominees
of this year's Google Play Awards thank
you now I would like to introduce Fergus
Raleigh product manager Google Play
thanks ray hi everyone my name is Fergus
Hurley I'm product manager in Google
Play I'm here to talk to about reviews
so building on top of the phenomenal
engagement that developers have had with
the reply to reviews functionality we've
made a lot of enhancements to the
ratings and views functionality and play
over the last few months we've added
being able to see your ratings over time
be able to see ratings breakdown across
country language device be able to see
the device metadata for each individual
review Sigma to understand what was the
RAM of that user on that device and even
be able to search within all the reviews
we've also enabled you to be able to now
get an email notification when use
updates their review after you've
responded we also added highlights these
are snippets that users see when they
come to your app listing page on the
Play Store and they can be able to see
these to be able to make their purchase
decision you may have to see them in the
Play Developer console and you can be
able to figure out which ones are the
ones you want to be able to invest in
more and be able to respond to the
reviews that are happening in those
highlights this year at i/o we announced
reviews analysis single it's two parts
the first part is topics topics are
unique words that are relevant to your
application and we service them for
example for this language learning app
Klingon is the top topic is and you can
see that there's the average effect on
rating of each one of these and the
volume distribution for each of these
topics we even tell you what is the
effect that each one of these is having
on your overall rating in the Play Store
the next part of the reviews analysis is
benchmarks benchmarks shows you what are
the common topics that people talk about
your application and nearly all other
applications on the Play Store you can
be able to see design stability resource
usage and then you can be able to see
how you compare to the other apps in
your category in the Play Store we also
show you what is the effect that each
one of these common topics is having on
your rating in the Play Store so you can
be able to prioritize your investment of
your resources and even have your team
be able to go in and be able to read all
the reviews about design for now the
reviews analysis works for English only
and only when you have a certain number
of reviews that fall within these
categories so what when we have all
these reviews on the Play Store and we
have this ability to be able to do
reviews analysis under all the reviews
we said let's have a look at all the
reviews and see what are the common
topics that are impacting one star in
five star reviews to help developers be
able to prioritize their investments and
be able to find out how to get a higher
rating on Play what we found is that
across all the one-star reviews
that have a common topic 50% are about
stability so really investing in
building a high quality app that does
not crash is really important we also
found that for when you want to get your
app to a five-star app and you fix the
stability issues really investing in
design performance and usability and
speed of your application is really
really important because that results in
65% of the five-star reviews we also
launched at i/o this year the reviews
API this enables you to be able to
respond to your reviews on the Play
Store with whatever workflow you use
yourself to be able to do customer
support we partnered with Zendesk and
commerce social on this launch and you
can be able to use those tools today to
be able to start responding to your Play
Store reviews now going to hand over to
Ricardo givanni who's the engineering
manager in play hello so today I'm here
to give you tips how you can better
understand who your users are and where
they come from you're probably familiar
with the user acquisition report that we
launched in the Play Developer console
last year it tells you how many sterling
visitors installed your app and convert
it into buyers and it does so by
breaking the information down by
acquisition channel so you know how many
people discover your app organical in
the Play Store versus coming from
different channels like your website or
AdWords campaigns over the past year we
received great feedback about this
feature like this one from Trulia and it
helped many developers like you optimize
your business in play so you'll be happy
to hear that we recently announced a new
feature being able to measure your user
acquisition performance at a country
level and this is great when you're
entering new markets like emerging ones
like Brazil or India and really optimize
your app experience for all your users
across the world but optimizing your
business performance in isolation is not
really that helpful how do you know for
example if you look at your organic
conversion rate if it is as good as it
could be
if your living opportunities on the
table so right now it's not that easy
but we're about to make it a lot better
so soon we will be launching another
great feature benchmarks against your
peers so you will be able to compare how
your store listing conversion rate first
against similar apps in your category
first will provide an overall benchmark
about your organic user acquisition
performance and this will give you an
indication on now your store listing is
performing globally but more you will be
able also able to measure your user
acquisition performance at a country
level against the benchmark at that
level for example here you can see that
our app is getting some traction in
Korea but at 24% we are lagging behind
the benchmark this is a moment where
maybe you want to review the quality of
your store listing translations or
consider localizing your assets will
also give you an indication on how
you're progressing against the benchmark
so you know if you still have room for
improvement or if you're really among
the best and aim for the top and when
you're ready to take action Play
Developer console has plenty of features
to help you optimize your store listing
performance and your regional success
such as stewed listing experiments or
app translation services and we'll offer
a recommendation about those right next
to the benchmarking results weren't
relevant so this is everything I have in
store for you today I believe that with
country breakdowns and benchmarks you
will be able to even better optimize
your business imply benchmarks is gonna
roll out over the next few weeks
country breakdowns is already there go
give it a try and now I'd like to
introduce on stage Manav agile a product
manager on Play thank you
thanks for pardon I'm here to talk about
what we are doing in Google Play for the
next billion users Android is growing
really fast in emerging markets by 2018
we expect 1.2 billion new Android users
to come online in emerging markets in
Google Play we have been working really
hard to make sure those users have a
great experience especially given some
of the infrastructure challenges in
those markets one key pillar is to have
a product and an ecosystem of apps that
work well on slow connections and unload
end devices our user studies have shown
over and over again that connectivity
and data challenges affect all users in
emerging markets regardless of where
they live or how much money they make
connectivity challenges are here to stay
by 2020
still 300 million users in India will be
on connection types that are equivalent
on to of 2g and even when Wi-Fi is
available it is often patchy and
unreliable so one of the key areas of
focus for us in Google Play has been to
build an experience that is fast
lightweight and reliable for every user
regardless of their connection type can
find and download apps that need their
needs over the past year we have
optimized the performance of the Play
Store app and they did much faster on 2g
we have also reduced the amount of data
used by the store itself and four key
activities like downloading apps and
updating apps these changes have brought
more users to the store they visit the
store more often that and they download
more apps we also know that our users
everywhere especially in emerging
markets want a store experience that
reflects their local interests and the
needs of their country and their region
we've been working closely with local
developers in markets like India and
Brazil to make sure those apps reach
their local audience in the store in
addition we've been
supercharging our editorial content in
the store to make sure users are able to
easily find locally relevant apps that
meet the needs of different segments of
user in the market and with that I like
to bring up to stage Kunal Soni who is
the head of absent games business
development in Southeast Asia thank you
thanks Laura hi everyone I'm here to
talk to you about creating great quality
apps that will work effectively not just
for smartphone users today but also for
the next billion users as they get
connected in the years to come we're
seeing incredible momentum in emerging
markets all around the world they were
expected to account for 80% of total
smartphone growth globally in order to
be relevant and successful in these
markets it's important for us to design
the right app experience aimed at
solving three important challenges
firstly while 4G and LTE and other
networked technologies will grow fast
they will still be 1 billion mobile
Internet users in 2020 who will be on 2g
that's a sizable segment for you to
think about and solve for secondly
mobile data speeds vary a lot across
markets requiring you to tailor the app
experience accordingly and finally data
is expensive relative to income levels
in several markets and therefore helping
your users manage their data costs
should be an important priority in order
to help you tackle these challenges and
support your growth we've identified a
set of tools and best practices that we
believe can help you this is what is
called the building for billions
framework focused on three important
areas connectivity device compatibility
and data cost by the way what I'm
covering here is by no means limited to
emerging markets these principles will
apply equally well across the world
let's start by looking at connectivity
in order to optimize for unreliable or
intermittent connectivity ensure that
your app prioritizes bandwidth requests
fetching text before rich media or data
ensure that you offer a great offline
experience so that all your users can
interact with the app at all times
regardless of a connectivity using
cached data let's talk about devices
many devices in emerging markets have
smaller lower resolution screens in
order to ensure a seamless user
experience across devices use
density-independent pixels while
defining a play outs ensure that your
graphics and text work well on low and
medium density screens and adjust your
memory footprint dynamically to ensure
compatibility across devices with
different Ram configurations finally
let's talk about data cost the first
cost your users will incur will be
related to the cost of installation of
your app and therefore it's important to
keep a tight focus on reducing the apk
size
ideally well below 10 megabytes in order
to accomplish this you should reduce the
number and size of images within the apk
using tools like WebP II and scalable
vector graphics or SVG you can shrink
the code size of your apk using tools
like ProGuard which remove unused code
and finally you can consider multi apk
as an option to create apks split by
density so that users target the right
version of the app that specifically
targets their device density with that
we come to the end of my session if
you're interested to know more do join
us for the session on building for
billions in Android today at 3 p.m. next
I'd like to invite milena Nicholas
engineering manager on Google Play thank
you
thanks canal hi I'm Elena
engineering manager on Google Play I'm
here to talk to you about play console
app yes we finally launched an Android
app for Google Play Developer console
thank you thank you we have to admit
that it took us a while it took us much
longer than it took you guys but we've
made it and we can tell you this app
stuff is pretty sweet we we really like
it now our new app can help you follow
the performance with your app on Google
Play and do time critical actions on the
go when you're rapidly iterating you
need a powerful tool that's in your
pocket all the time and we've built play
console app exactly with those use cases
in mind whether you're looking to
quickly reply to user review or to show
off the performance of your app when
running to a meeting play console app
should be there to support you regarding
an initial feature set obviously you can
check installs and uninstalls of your
app and you can break them down based on
the number of different dimensions
including country device app version and
much more in addition to that you can
check out crash reports including hourly
data and full stack traces you can also
follow your apps ratings and reviews and
you can reply to reviews you can also
follow the state of your release as it
moves from beta through stage roll out
all the way to production and much more
so also you can get push notifications
when something important happens with
your app for example when your app
update goes live app is now available on
Google Play in the last 24 hours
since we launched it more than 10,000
developers installed it and rated it at
4.8 4.8 e 5 stars on average if you're
not among those 10,000 developers please
please go and install it we think you'll
find it very useful also we are very
keen to hear your feedback so please
send us any feedback that you have we
plan to work on it we plan to add much
more very much more functionality
in the next couple of versions and if
you're still not convinced please do
come visit us in the place and box where
you can see it in action for yourself
thank you
next I would like to invite Suresh
Ganapati and shobhona Ravi thanks velena
so we showed you a sneak preview of
android and synapse the keynote
yesterday today I want to tell you a
little bit more about how to build
Android and synapse and the new
opportunities that this could open up
first let's do a quick recap of the
announcement yesterday for those of you
who aren't around so android instant
apps lets you access apps by simply
tapping on links even if you don't have
the app installed as a developer this
means that this is just an upgrade to
your existing Android app this is not a
new separate app it's compatible with
Android jelly bean and up and will reach
over a billion users now we understand
that this is a big change and we want to
get it ripe so we're gonna be rolling
this out gradually to boat users and
developers over the next year so let's
talk about how you'd upgrade your app to
run instantly as a developer you start
by telling us the links to your domain
that your app can open this is really
easy to do with Android Apple Inc's
which we announced last year next if
your app is really big you may want to
consider it splitting it into modules
this allows Google Play to download only
the parts of the app that are required
on the fly when the user taps on a link
next we think that users may have
slightly different expectations of what
an app can do when it's running
instantly so instant apps will not have
access to some capabilities like
creating a home screen widget finally
we're building a whole new set of
features for instant apps that we want
you to take advantage of my favorite is
runtime permissions android instant apps
will use one-time permissions going all
the way back to jelly bean now I want to
talk a little bit about some new
opportunities that in synapse can
open up we've hacked together a couple
of fun demos that I want to show you as
examples can we switch to the demo feed
please
okay so instant apps lets you deliver
the same rich and immersive experiences
to both users who have installed your
app and the ones who haven't so the demo
here is my buddy Jake created this
really cool photo sharing app it can
capture panoramas and display them as
really unique way now he sent me a
picture that he captured with this app
when he was on a trip to Machu Picchu I
really want to see the picture that he
shared but I'm not quite sure if I want
to install the app as yet with instant
apps this is not a problem all I have to
do is tap a link with one tap the app
opens up instantly deep linked right to
the panorama that Jake shared it even
uses the sensors on the phone to pan the
image as Chauvin and moves the device
isn't that amazing thank you at the
other end of the spectrum instant apps
also lets you create very lightweight
apps that don't even have to take the
user out of context of what they were
doing
joven and I recently made plans to go to
a concert so I booked my tickets as a
shins concert and I sent her a message
asking her to book hers now she doesn't
have the ticketing app on her phone when
she taps the link the app opens up
instantly but it didn't open up as a
full screen app it opened up just as a
dialog is all the information she needs
prefilled her seats are right next to
mine and with Android pay it's one tap
to pay all of this while the hangouts
app is still in the background
Jovana thank you
shobhona didn't have to leave her
conversation with me to buy these
tickets this can be really interesting
if you want to help the user complete a
simple task with as little friction as
possible so those are the two examples
that we have for you today can we switch
back please
can we switch back to the slides
we'll be just a moment perfect I wanted
you to see the the URL so you can learn
more so if you go to GGO forward slash
instant apps you can learn more there
there's a sign-up form if you're
interested in upgrading your app to run
instantly with that I'd like to
introduce further market seeker who
leads plays global business ultimate
team on stage thank you thank you sir
age how many think that instant apps are
amazing you know I have been so excited
I was in an uber this morning and it was
on the radio
and I was like thrilled to bits good
morning everyone
I am Poornima coochie car and I work for
you my team and I have the great
privilege to work with each and every
one of you to help you build successful
businesses on Google Play Android powers
increasingly new screens across new
markets empowering people across the
world and it is this scale that allows
Google Play to provide you the largest
app distribution platform in the world
let's look at some numbers in 2015 1
billion monthly active users across a
hundred and ninety countries drove 65
billion installs on Google Play
mind-boggling isn't it in 2015 the
number of game developers who had a game
with more than 1 million installs grew
by over 50% which means more people are
being successful and if you look back
and you say ok there is installs there
is more installs per game but are we
making money in 2015 the average spend
per user across Play
grew by over 30% when compared to 2014
so as you can see we have a very
thriving community waiting for the
things that you create these are
incredibly impressive numbers but none
of it would be possible without you our
developer community so where I sit on a
daily basis we see developers across the
world big and small creating apps that
change lives and games that delight each
day my team and I are inspired and
humbled by how you are taking your
personal passions and converting them
into successful businesses I hope the
video that Ellie shared with you was as
inspirational to you as it is to us over
the last year we connected with 1
million of you across various channels
to help you understand and access the
tools we are building as well as to tell
you about the market opportunities that
are there in front of you you heard
today emerging markets the MA you know
new ways to build your business all
these tools to really help you build
your business now here's the interesting
thing each of those instances we learnt
we figured out how to improve our
products so I hope you will take the
time to visitors in the sandbox to tell
us how we can do things better and I'm
also excited to see what you will do
with the new capabilities that we have
announced today we also use this
opportunity to get you connected with
each other how many of you are sitting
with people that you already know should
you be so I hope you take this
opportunity to really step out and need
each other understand what everybody is
doing there is people from around the
globe here today it is a unique
opportunity and therefore I am extremely
excited to announce the very first
Google Play Awards this evening 7:00
p.m. at stage 7 you can't forget that 7
p.m. at stage 7 so please come to see
the great apps and games that are being
showcased get inspired join us thank you
very much for coming and here's how you
can keep in touch with us we hope to see
you this evening at 7 p.m. thank you